- If you've been on internet recently
you've seen these beautiful, silver balls.
They're mesmerizing to look at,
and they are actually
made out of aluminum foil.
Apparently it takes hours to do.
I think when people hear
"shove aluminum together,
hammer it, and then sand it",
they think any idiot could do that.
So, I'm the idiot that's gonna do that.
(upbeat music)
My strategy is to take a blob of tinfoil,
shove it into a ball, hammer it, sand it.
How hard can it be?
I hope this isn't poison.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Stupid space rock.
Why did I think I could do this?
Let's do it.
I feel like go big or go home, right?
'Cause when you hammer it
it's gonna get much smaller,
so this is a big boy.
This is the ball we're starting with.
It's kind of like how you
turn carbon into a diamond.
(grunts)
And then it's something beautiful.
So this might take hours.
No one has to stay.
You don't have to stay.
It started in Japan,
which I think is where
most cool things start.
It feels good to hit things.
I have to compress it
before I can smooth it.
You can see I kind of started
to make this area circular.
- 20 minutes?
Eight minutes?
Are you fucking kidding me?
It's kind of like an indent right there,
so my next goal is to make
this into an actual sphere.
I'm trying to pep myself up.
Kids can do this.
I can do this, I'm an adult.
The roll and the smushing is probably
the most important step,
and I think I fucked up.
So, gonna try and salvage this.
You know what?
I need Ashley.
Ashley does a lot of DIY stuff,
so I'm gonna find her.
Look at that balloon,
it's just like bragging
about how round it is.
- Hello.
- Ashley.
This is where I am,
and is there any way to salvage this?
- It's not gonna be a sphere.
I think you can get it
to like an egg shape.
- Egg?
- I haven't seen that yet.
- Oh no.
Harder than it looks I guess.
What do you, oh, I'm gonna fall.
- More aggressive.
Maybe take a little bit off of there.
- Just chop the head off.
- Yeah so it's a little more ball-esque.
- Think you Hal.
No one's being very helpful.
You know what?
I'm gonna take this basketball
and I'm gonna take it and use it as inspo.
This isn't a ball and it looks bad.
But good news, we got
in touch with the guy
who basically created
the whole phenomenon.
He can tell me exactly how to do this.
Well, he speaks Japanese and I don't,
but not a problem because
we have people at Buzzfeed
who can translate for me.
And while we wait for that,
I'm gonna keep going
and do my own research.
Oh, he's showing us how to do it.
- Yeah.
- Hammer as you unroll?
All right, we're starting over, okay?
Under this system we pull it out,
fold it like this, we
fold it like a triangle,
and then we roll it in,
we kind of crunch it in.
We start the ball here people.
Do a little hammering as we go.
Oh Jesus this is an important step.
People see things online and think,
"yeah, I can do that", and they can't.
But maybe if they fail enough, they can.
I'm starting with something that's
a lot more of a ball shape.
My faith is restored 'cause
this looks pretty good.
I'm gonna move on to stage
two, which is sanding.
I think you start coarser and go finer,
so we're gonna start with
an 80 and then go to 220.
It's looking pretty good.
Before when I was doing this,
people would walk by, they
had no idea what I was doing,
now people walk by and they're like,
"oh, the thing you put in the microwave".
Oh, my silver hands.
- [Group] Sarah, Sarah, Sarah!
- Yeah, it's a ball, thank you!
- [Man] Don't give up ever, all day!
It's only Wednesday.
- [Girl] I don't know.
- Once you get to the thousands,
those are the really fine and that's where
you're gonna get your shine out of them.
- We only have to 220.
- You probably want to get like 1500 grit.
'Cause then you wet it up a little bit
and then they kind of like.
- My word.
- Oh there's such a thing as.
- [Woman] Yeah, wet sanding.
- Wow.
Do you want me to go get the 1500?
- So now we've got the 2000 and the 1500.
And so now we should be able to
actually make this ball smooth.
You think I dip this in and
then sand where it's wet.
I'm gonna get a little wet
and then we're sanding.
Ooh, I do see it working.
Five hours in, I'm not there yet.
This takes forever to do.
This project is not
for the faint of heart.
I mean it really is starting
to look pretty cool,
it's just that I'm tired of doing it.
All right, I'm gonna pause
this stuff so we don't, ugh.
It's day two and I'm back trying to make
a ball of foil shinier
than it needs to be.
(beeping)
Oh, that's the sound of my microwave.
Looks like it's done.
Wow, there you have it.
And that's how, I'm just
kidding, don't do that.
Don't put your foil ball in the microwave,
that's a really bad idea.
A very funny tweet, but a really bad idea.
I spent all of last night sanding.
I actually googled like a hand workout.
My hand's never hurt so much.
Sanding,
Brad's cooking dinner and I'm
trying to make my ball shiny.
Still sanding.
Hopefully it'll be good enough
to polish tomorrow morning, hopefully.
And we're gonna shortly
move on to polishing.
We got a shiny ball, we're
gonna make it shinier.
Let's do this.
Ooh, creamy.
So we're gonna do this a little bit
and I might sand with it too
because that was one of the
tips we picked up online,
to maybe try to, oh.
This smell is overpowering.
How do people work?
Oh god.
So got a little bit of that on there.
I'm polishing and sanding together
because that's something I saw online.
It's not the kind of smell
you really want to inhale.
Can you smell it?
No?
Okay, that's good, at least it's just me.
I'm sweating again.
DIY is a workout, but like
this shiny ball is a real workout.
- Yes, you can.
- What?
So Max just told me that we finally have
communicated with the
originator of the tinfoil ball.
My coworker Sarah was able to translate it
so we're gonna go talk to her.
Yeah I know I am almost done my ball,
but I figured better late than never.
Let's find out what he says.
- It says, my younger
brother developed the method
of making aluminum foil balls himself.
I usually make clockwork dolls,
I make aluminum foil balls
as part of that work.
You can make an aluminum foil ball in
like an hour to an hour and a half.
The only tool necessary is a hammer.
- [Sarah] No.
- He doesn't use any kind of abrasive.
Hit it a bunch of times
really hard with a hammer.
The aluminum foil will turn into one mass
with no gaps in between it.
Turns out I wasted hours, maybe even days,
making it a more complicated
way, but you know what?
Still gonna finish it.
- Have fun.
- At the end I'll maybe feel proud,
but right now I just feel angry.
Now I'm back to polishing.
Let's do it, let's do it bitch.
I'll do it a little bit more.
And now I have to go with a
dry cloth and wipe it down
and hopefully, this'll be the last,
beautiful, pristine
version of my shiny ball.
I feel so accomplished.
I'm proud.
Looks good, right?
This was my first
attempt, and now I'm here.
I got a shiny ball.
If I had buffing machine
it would have been perfect,
but with my hands, which are in pain,
I did this.
Things might look easy to do online,
it might look like you just take tinfoil,
smush it into a ball,
buff it, and there you go,
but that's not the case.
You need to do your research,
you need to see what
other people are doing,
the mistakes they've made,
so you don't make the same mistakes.
So I hope you have a better
idea of how to do it.
Or if you're like me,
have your friends that are
good at DIY make this for you
and pay them a lot of money
'cause it will take hours to make.
It's kind of like a crystal ball.
It's not that shiny,
but don't they do this?
Am I doing the right thing?
Ooh, what do I see in your future?
Probably like a lot of
blisters on your hands
because you made this ball.